hey wendy how you doing very well thanks
that's good any new projects you're
working on now that your show's over oh
excuse me i love morton ira and we bowed
out gracefully wendy williams steps out
in new york and shares an update after
her talk show's demise we've got a lot
to talk about
wendy is at peace with how her show
ended after 13 seasons now she's focused
on her future in life and love a source
tells e.t quote she is extremely happy
and focused on new beginnings wendy's
show came to an end earlier this month
today is the final episode of the wendy
williams show there is nobody
nobody like wendy williams
from her days on the radio to ruling
daytime talk for 13 seasons
wendy earned her title as the queen of
all media she was m.i.a from what turned
out to be the series farewell season a
combination of health issues and legal
battles seemingly keeping her away from
her iconic purple chair but now she's
ready for a comeback and she's headed
back to her radio roots with a 20 22
twist uh podcast of course okay which
will make more money for me than doing
the tv show
producing her own podcast all comes down
to money for wendy we wouldn't be
surprised if it also keeps fans updated
on everything wendy including her
ongoing health battle she recently
revealed to tmz she has lymphedema a
condition that causes swelling in your
arms or legs wendy says she can only
feel about five percent of her feet but
that's not slowing her down okay let's
get started it's time for
come on
the media personality has definitely
paid her dues in the industry our e.t
source says the 57-year-old host knows
she doesn't have to work another day in
her life if she chooses to
wendy's focus is starting new chapters
by quote diving into new business
endeavors investing continuing on her
health journey her family let me tell
you what had happened
speaking of growing people doing asinine
things after years of her marriage being
a hot topic as cheating rumors swirled
wendy finalized her divorce from
ex-husband kevin hunter in 2020. i don't
have time for a lot of foolishness now
our source says wendy's open to taking
another shot at love quote wendy wants
to fall in love and knows that's exactly
what she deserves
no regrets
[Music]
you